he goes oh hey I'm going to dinner with
Eric at 7:30 mind you I've been sick all
weekend then offer me no food no meds
then offer me a kiss or a hug shut the
[ __ ] up with your oh man
you didn't can you look at me right now
wait wait stop right now right now no
that's not right your baby I'm sorry I
apologize but look at me right now if
you ever give me a [ __ ] oh like that
again my friend all right
you have another thing coming which is I
don't know mystery it's a mystery one
all right so I want you to a [ __ ]
apologize Gilbert I'm sorry that I said
oh and you didn't kiss your girlfriend
when you got home
you're welcome and I forgive you go
ahead baby I mean the same argument we
always have I have a pretty high
threshold for video the best girlfriend
the world I don't tell him when to stop
I don't give him like a baby baby baby
yesterday I was sick and I just needed a
little bit of like high kalila I know
you exist and you're sick and you're
dying on a bed I needed just just an
ounce of it I know that's it and I was
trying to communicate that to him and
all he said to me was I'm after playing
ten hours he says I don't want to talk
about it I'm too tired I need a nap and
then he goes okay yeah yeah and then he
wakes up he goes to dinner and then a
dinner he realizes what he had done I
stop stop stop stop stop okay number one
okay I want you to apologize I want you
to apologize right now kalila for what
just to do it he always makes me do this
yeah yeah just to do it you see I am so
sorry
you know what Bobbi I really am sorry
that you have just zero
capacity I heard sorry and that's all I
needed and number two okay I invited you
to dinner and number three I'm gonna
tell you what happened at dinner
Oh Oh what happened at dinner so number
one I had dinner with Kat Blaque
Erik Griffin everyone knows that black
yeah and Pat Blair does he call you
stuff man but anyway um [ __ ] FET
something like that oh man I think I've
heard that and we go to our parks now I
don't know if you guys know my
relationship with parks barbecue on
Vermont
but for many many years I'd had to walk
in there and there was all these
celebrity photos of people that been in
there some that you know never even
[ __ ] heard of you have an Asian wall
of fame yeah I'm no idea who those
people and um our photo was under and
one of our vans compliment Pig
compliment pig walked into parks
barbecue and put up a photo of me and
[ __ ] kalila and they framed it
amazing and they put it up there he
framed it then he put it on the wall he
did yep
but porks kept it up there mm-hmm but
guess what happened yesterday
no I walk in it's gone they took it down
no they put it upstairs but no one eats
upstairs
there wasn't upstairs I never knew there
was even an upstairs I thought that was
like for private party I almost went to
Eric we might have to eat somewhere else
this is blasphemy and this is almost
called the cops I don't know what I
would have said almost dead hey Los
Angeles police yeah um hi hello who is
this
I suspect about I don't care okay you
know what's weird were the cops
all right fine all right why won't you
say this I've spent about probably about
over my lifetime ten thousand dollars at
this restaurant okay sir and I'm kind of
a celebrity who are you
Bob Bob Barker Bob just Bob yes okay you
know who I am
yeah you're the Charles I'm sorry Bobby
and I'll check it out dawg
and I'm Korean right yeah he said right
and Parks what kind of restaurant is it
Korean right
owned by what Korean that's right dawg
and I want to say officer that anyway um
I put a photo up me because there's a
celebrity wall and there's my photo was
on I put it up
and then they took it down and I want to
call it I don't care that's one calling
you Charles the Cherokee doesn't get
them okay we'll take care of it okay
thank you
that's what I wanted Wow right [ __ ]
great police but can I say something
what do you think is why I'll tell you
why you don't know why I dunno why let
me [ __ ] finish the story man during
dinner email lady she's a god here she's
a god right she was hello hi your father
you're upstairs
no I go oh okay
and I know right that we didn't put the
photo in the road do you call me out I
go yeah I know
it's okay a big fan of yours right I got
oh cool
she the reason why you're up there is
because the photo down here have to be
with me you guys took a picture so we
took a photo there it is right and now
I'm on the wall the legit no no you're
sayin the [ __ ] wanted to nix me she
took out the kalila she does she does
she nixed you and she doesn't and also
Erik Griffin got all mad because that
what about me man like he said it out
loud
who the [ __ ] block yeah black I know
he's some sort of superhero that black
you never know and he couldn't get on
the wall all right he goes a little mad
about that but so that happened and I
want to apologize to you since you sorry
about your behavior yesterday I want to
apologize about my behavior and now
we're even
how did you still haven't explained your
whole apology and why it happened at
parks that's why you apologized it's
because you you were you started being a
good mood that someone took a photograph
with you no why why did you text me from
Park saying I'm sorry babe I love you
why cuz I felt bad at parks when you why
cuz all of a sudden your brain even the
nutrients hit your brain and you realize
you had made a mistake yeah okay makes
sense
he was just I said I didn't sleep that
night right I had two hours sleep so I
took a [ __ ] early flight from Austin
I started playing all day long I hadn't
eaten really it's such a liar because
when you came home you were like I paid
extra to fly home first class so I could
sit with the boy then oh my god I slept
the whole flight night yes that's it
three hours to three hours of flight so
when I need eight hours that's how my
body works okay full light I mean Jesus
babe I just you you know we both
apologize to each other and I thought it
was even I think we're even at this
point all right then
yeah we're good and everything's under
the log you know bridge under the bridge
yeah you know
[Music]